[Music]  Disney's live-action Beauty and the  Beast remake is out today and the ghast  is celebrating on social media who's  from the lost packing fool to play Belle  it just feels like such an honor Emma  Watson truly the belle of the ball in  this Instagram shot  she's mid twirl in that iconic yellow  gown writing Beauty and the Beast opens  today I hope you have as much fun  watching it as I did they eat it if my  five-year-old self knew I was gonna get  to do this she would have died and check  out the video Josh GAD tweeted he  surprised fans at several movie theatres  in New York on Thursday night I saw it  in the theater when I was 10 years old  and it was sort of a defining moment  because I remember sitting there and  hearing the audience applaud for these  characters singing these songs as if  they were gonna respond to the applause  and to now bring those songs to life to  bring this amazing story to life is a  thrill  [Music]  you